we got a ton of voicemails yesterday
about my interview with my pillow CEO
Mike Lindell I have to tell you I
struggled with how to conduct that
interview because he's so shot out of a
cannon and all over the place
and a lot of people criticized my
handling of the interview here's one
caller who thought that I did okay
hi David this is Bonnie from Utah yes
and I just wanted to tell you that I
really enjoyed your conversation with
Mike pillow
I was actually quite impressed with him
he didn't seem quite as
shall we say anxious and sweaty
as he sometimes does
so maybe he switched to decaf who knows
maybe
I was impressed with your interaction
with him
and uh your degree of respect
and your ability to reel in the
conversation when he sort of was trying
to jump out of the Corral yeah so
um good job I enjoy uh your program and
I'm a 65 year old liberal Progressive
broad from Utah
so yeah it is a challenge but keep up
the good work guys you're doing great
well I really appreciate that there were
positive comments and negative comments
about the interview
um there were people who wrote and said
I didn't interrupt enough there were
people who wrote and said I interrupted
too much uh etc etc I do the best I can
and I think it went okay and uh
generating now by the way he did say
many things that weren't true like for
example one of the things pillows
obviously one of the things he said was
none of the judges that threw out
election challenges threw them out on
merits only on standing
within minutes of the interview posting
someone emailed me a judge in Wisconsin
who threw out a case based on the merits
so it's it can be difficult to have all
the information handy as the interview
is going on and that's one of the big
challenges Sam Harris whatever you think
about Sam Harris accurately describes
the difficulty with these interviews
where he says someone can you can only
be so prepared they can always find
something you're not familiar with they
show up and they make some statement
about they set a bunch of small fires
and now you have to figure out how to
put each fire out and it can be very
difficult and that certainly was a
factor yesterday we've got a great bonus
show for you today producer Pat is back
no longer under the weather we will talk
about new concerns about a PayPal draft
leak we will talk about the Uvalde
Uvalde Uvalde School District suspending
its entire police department we will
talk about the latest on self-driving
cars which I think you will find
interesting and much more get the bonus
show by signing up at joinpakman.com